how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock well I'll tell you what
you're my kind of people because I grew
up on a farm in West St Louis County and
we started out with beef calves and if
you raise livestock the only way you can
make money is if you raise a lot of your
own feed for those of you don't have
that experience and so we raised our own
corn and we raised our own soybeans in
our own hay
and we had a truck come out from the
mill and this truck would come out from
the mill and it would grind up the corn
and the soybeans and the hay and then we
would add sacks of vitamins minerals
trace minerals and we make pellets out
of it and this is what we would feed the
calves in six months time we'd ship them
to Market to be slaughtered we'd save
back some of the best ones for herself
we'd knock them in the head and eat them
put it bluntly and it always fascinated
me as a teenager that we did that for
those calves and in six months ship them
off to be slaughtered or we'd eat them
and we wanted to live to be a hundred
years of age without any aches and pains
and guess what we didn't take any
vitamins or minerals
and that bothered me
so I asked my dad I'd say hey Pops how
come you do that for those calves you
don't do that for us and he'd give me
this good old Missouri farm wisdom he'd
say things like shut up boy you're
getting this farm fresh food and we hope
you appreciate it
and of course I was very quiet then
because I didn't want to miss out on any
meals well then when I went to school I
went to the University of Missouri
school of Agriculture and I got my
degree in agriculture I got my major and
animal husbandry in nutrition my minor
was in field crops and soils and then I
got into veterinary school
as a freshman Veterinary student I
learned the answer to my question
and the answer is this we know how to
prevent and cure diseases in animals
with nutrition and the reason why we do
that is because we don't have major
medical we don't have hospitalization
Blue Cross Blue Shield we don't have
Medicare
if you're going to make money as a
farmer you better know how to do stuff
yourself and you better do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can
to make a long story short after I got
out of a veterinary school I went to
Africa for two years and I was able to
fulfill a Boyhood dream I was able to be
a Frank Buck for two years and work with
Marlon Perkins many of you will remember
him from the Mutual of Omaha's Wild
Kingdom and he's a great gentleman and
after two years of working with
elephants and rhino people used to ask
me or are you a small animal vet or a
large animal vet well I was telling them
I'm an extra large animal vet because I
worked with elephants and rhinos well
after two years he sent me a telegram
and said would you come back to the St
Louis Zoo and work with us we need a
Wildlife veterinarian at the zoo for a
special project we were given a seven
and a half million dollar Grant from the
National Institutes of Health and what
we need as a veterinarian who will do
autopsies of animals to die of natural
causes in the zoo I was just Overjoyed
to do that and so I came back and and of
course I not only did autopsies for
animals that died in the St Louis Zoo
but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago the
Bronx Zoo New York the National Zoo the
LA Zoo and so forth and my job again was
to do autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the zoo and look for a
species of animals that was Ultra
sensitive to pollution
this is because during the early 60s we
had just learned about pollution and
ecological problems and disasters and
nobody quite knew what to do and so I
was supposed to find a species of
animals that was extra sensitive and
used them much like we did the canaries
in the mine you know the old Welsh coal
miners used to put a canary in a little
wicker cage and take it down in the mine
and if methane gas or carbon monoxide
would leak into the mine the canary
would drop off the perch and die first
and the men knew to get out before the
mine blew up or they suffocated again to
make a long story short over a period of
some 12 years I did 17 500 autopsies and
over 454 species of animals and 3 000
human beings who lived in close
proximity to zoos and the thing that I
found out was this every animal and
human being who dies of natural causes
dies of a nutritional deficiency
and that fascinated me it went back took
me back to those calves I said Gee
that's fascinating we could document
this at autopsy both chemically and
biochemically and things you saw with
the eye at the autopsy table well that
fascinated me and I wrote scientific
articles I wrote eight multi-author
textbooks and one textbook of my own
cost 140 bucks for medical students and
I'm sure the only thing they do is use
them for door stops
and it couldn't get anybody excited I
was on 2020
I was on 1700 newspapers
I was in magazines I was in every
Network TV that you can think of and
guess what couldn't get anybody excited
back in the 60s about nutrition
so what I did was went back to school
and became a physician to use everything
I had learned in veterinary school about
nutrition in my human patients and to no
surprise to me it worked I spent 12
years up in Portland Oregon in general
practice and it was very fascinating
what I'm going to share with you tonight
is what I learned over those 10 12 years
using nutrition with my human patients
and if you take home only 10 percent it
will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
Gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means a Gob
means a lot
okay it'll add many healthful years to
your life
well you can't do this you can't get
these healthful years you can't have
longevity you can't live to your genetic
potential just falling off a stump
you have to do some things the first
thing I have to do is convince you that
it is worth doing these things now I'm
going to start out by convincing you
that the genetic potential for human
beings is 120 years our genetic
potential for longevity in May 11th the
oldest living American at this time and
documented through the Guinness World
Book of Records was Margaret skeet she
was from Radford Virginia she died at
age 115 and she died of a nutritional
deficiency you can tell that from her
her obituary
has she died of the complications of a
fall
what does she die from osteoporosis very
good she died of a Calcium deficiency
she had no heart disease no cancer no
diabetes no other infirmities but she
died three weeks after a fall because
she didn't have enough calcium
her daughter said that she had a craving
for sweets until she died and that's a
disease called Pica we'll talk about
that in a little bit but usually when
you have a craving for chocolate if
you're a chocoholic or a sugar-a-holic
that means that you have a deficiency
been in a third world country in Niger
and Africa a chief by the name of Bauer
at age 126 was eulogized by one of his
wives and she was bragging about him at
his death at age 126. he was still in
possession of all his own teeth okay so
you assume that other faculties are
working too
okay
then here's a gentleman from Syria at
age 133 he died in July of 1993. he
fathered nine children after the age of
80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
hundred so there's still hope for you
fellas
then those of you who like science in
November of 1993 those six biosperians
came out of that dome in Arizona they
were in there for two years three
couples and they were supposed to eat
the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
whatnot and have no pollution in their
water or air or food and when they came
out they were examined by medical
gerontologists from UCLA University of
California at Los Angeles they put all
this information their physical and
their blood work and so forth into the
medical computers at UCLA and the
medical computers projected that they
could live to be 165 years old if they
continued to do what they were doing so
all of that just says to you that
there's a there's a possibility you can
live to be 120 and when I grew up on the
farm we could grow 200 bushels of corn
per acre and with all the labor and all
the fertilizer and everything else you
did
you could make a profit if you grew 200
bushels per acre but if you only got a
hundred bushels per acre and put out
that same effort in the same fertilizer
cost you'd lose money
and so I want you to think about it the
average lifespan for an American today
is 75.5
the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is 58.
you want to gain 20 years statistically
just don't go to medical school
you want to live to be 120 there's only
two basic things it's real simple two
things to remember number one you have
to avoid the pitfalls you have to not
step on the land mines I call it and
those are in the military you know what
that means you do something stupid like
step on one of those things you kill
yourself wastefully or unnecessarily of
course if you play Russian Roulette or
smoke excessively or drink excessively
or wear a black sweatsuit and run down
the middle of the highway at two o'clock
in the morning you're going to get
struck by a car all of those things are
foolhardy but it's amazing how many tens
of thousands of people die in America
from doing those stupid things every
year the last thing I will share with
you on that subject of avoiding the
landmines I'd suggest very strongly to
you that you avoid going to doctors
and I'm going to back up that statement
which is a pretty strong statement from
Ralph Nader's group in January of 1993
just about a year and a half ago January
13th he put out a news release based on
a three-year study on the causes of
death in American hospitals and it was
1500 page report this three-year study
and I'm not going to waste your time or
Mine by going over the whole thing word
for word but the bottom line says a lot
quote three hundred thousand Americans
are killed each year and hospitals alone
as a result of medical negligence
unquote I'm going to read that figure
again because it's a huge figure quote
300 000 Americans are killed each year
in hospitals alone as a result of
medical negligence unquote he didn't say
He Slipped Away quietly out of neglect
in a corner somewhere while they're
waiting for an x-ray he is the word
killed when you use the word killed that
means there was a procedure the doctor
was doing went wrong somehow it means
that they gave them a wrong prescription
they put a decimal point in the wrong
spot and gave them an incorrect dosage
these people were killed
three hundred thousand to appreciate how
big a figure that is you have to compare
that with our military losses in Vietnam
over 10 years where we lost 56 000
people over 10 years or an average of
only 5 600 a year
on a field of battle where people had
guns and artillery and explosives trying
to kill each other and millions of
people poured out into the streets and
protested that war we had political
Anarchy in the last three years of the
war students took over universities and
colleges with guns and explosives
National Guardsmen shot students at Kent
State in Ohio
we chased a president out of the
presidency for 5 600 military personnel
a year and here's one profession that
takes your tax money in the form of
Medicare and Medicaid and kills three
hundred thousand of us a year according
to Ralph Nader and I believe him he has
no acts to grind
and you can go out in the street any day
of the week in any City and there isn't
even a crazy Street Preacher out there
with a sign that says protect us from
doctors
I want you to think about that folks
that's number one
you have to avoid stepping on the land
mine so there's a certain value in
treating yourself when you can or
preventing disease they don't have to
get treated now the second thing you
have to do number two is you have to do
the positive things you have to do the
positive things and I'm going to start
out here by just putting a figure up on
the board it's the number 90 and you
need 90 nutrients in your diet every day
you need 60 minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts
I can tell you that I was one of those
nerds back when I was in college I had a
clipboard we didn't have computers back
then so I had a clipboard and I was one
of those funny guys with glasses and
would walk up and down in the Student
Union there in Columbia and say do you
take vitamins and minerals I was still
fascinated by that and and of course
people kind of look at you crazy and say
well yeah I take vitamin E
and I'd wait for him to come up with the
other 89 and they didn't they just oh I
take vitamin E well today if you ask
people do you take food supplements they
say oh yeah I take Tums
because that's what you know they hear
all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it but
the newspaper is no and then magazines
and TV and radio knows that we're
interested in Health and Longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stead the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers well my
favorite article of all time appeared in
Time Magazine April 6 1992 and if you
haven't read it I'd urge you to get it
out of a school library or public
library and photocopy it stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator to cover article and it
says the real power of vitamins new
research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
Aging again there's six positive pages
in here there's only one negative
sentence and we was issued by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article what do you think what do
you think about vitamins and minerals
for people is food supplements and
here's what the doctor said quote
popping vitamins doesn't do you any good
sniffs Dr Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well wad up your dollars and throw
them in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published so it must be true
right
after having done those seventeen
thousand five hundred autopsies and 454
species of animals from around the world
and 3 000 humans and liking to be
healthy myself and having children and
grandchildren in the not too distant
future children I'd rather pee out 50
cents or a dollar a day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals is pretty cheap
insurance
if you don't invest in yourself to the
tune of a buck a day for vitamins and
minerals guess what you're going to
invest in the lifestyle of an MD
somewhere because when you pay the
medical doctor your fee for going to see
him
not one penny of that goes to study how
to diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease in a little child
like who was in here earlier are how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer prostate cancer in adults
guess what that money goes for pays a
doctor's mortgage makes his Mercedes
payment
it pays a tuition for his kids to go to
medical school and have it you never
have it is up in Boston pays a tuition
for his kids to go to law school at Yale
between 1776 and the Second World War
the U.S government spent 80 million
dollars on health care and Health Care
research and studies right now we're
1.2 trillion dollars a year for health
care
and it's free
we all know it's free right
it's not free but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff I'll tell
you what if we used a human type medical
system for the agricultural industry and
the livestock your hamburger costs 275
dollars a pound
on the other hand if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans your monthly
insurance premiums for a family of five
would be ten dollars a month
you take your choice
well I believe since we've made them
wealthy through Insurance programs and
government subsidies I believe they owe
us something I believe they owe us at
least as much as the industries do
according to for instance recall notices
this was started of course I don't know
25 years ago when Ralph Nader learned
that the Ford Motor Company had made a
pinto car with a rear-end gas tank that
would blow up when you got hit from
behind at 20 miles an hour fry everybody
in the car and when people complained to
Ford Motor Company they said well you're
just dumb for getting in a car accident
we're not going to pay you for that
Ralph Nader says no it's a faulty design
so he went to a federal court and the
judge agreed with them and through a
court order forced Ford Motor Company to
send everybody a recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing but they kill
300 000 a year and nobody protests as
long as we get ours free and that scares
me that attitude at any rate I've got a
bunch of these recall notices you should
have gotten over the last couple years
we'll go through them quickly number one
is ulcers how many of you ever heard
that ulcers is caused by stress
okay everybody's heard that if you don't
raise your hand you got Alzheimer's or
your fibbon right
well we knew 50 years ago in in the
veterinary industry that ulcers at least
in pigs was caused by a bacteria called
helicobacter pylori and of course we
couldn't get one of these high-priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo when they say stuff like that
otherwise your pork chops would be 275
dollars a pound to pay for that kind of
surgery and we learned that with a trace
mineral called bismuth and the
tetracycline antibiotic that we could
prevent and and cure those stomach
ulcers and pigs without surgery so
that's what we did cost five bucks to
cure a pig of stomach ulcers with the
Bismuth the trace mineral and
tetracycline well the National
Institutes of Health now not the
National Enquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said
ulcers are caused by a bacteria called
helicobacter pylori not stress
and they can be cured they actually use
the Cure word in this news release
medical researchers never do that they
always say shows promising results or
may be beneficial they use the Cure word
National Institutes of Health and they
say can be cured with a combination of
the trace mineral bismuth and
tetracycline
well for those of you don't know what
business comes in you can get it from
any grocery store or drugstore it's pink
about 295 for an eight ounce bottle and
it's called Pepto-Bismol
so a teaspoon a day full of Pepto-Bismol
and some oramycin calf scour pellets you
can take care of ulcers
now you have your choice where you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get whittled on that's your choice
then what's the number two cause of
death in Americans terrible disease
called cancer right
now doctors get information on cancer
you'd think they'd photocopy that when
they send you that bill they should send
you some photocopies of this stuff well
in September of 1993 the National Cancer
Institute not the National Enquirer but
the National Cancer Institute and the
Harvard Medical School up in Boston did
a study on cancer patients and they came
out and they said an anti-cancer diet
was found
well anyway they picked China to do this
study because in one Province henan
Province in China they have the highest
rate of cancer in the whole world they
took 29 000 people for five years in
this study and what they did was give
them different vitamins and minerals at
Double the recommended daily allowance
for Americans now that's a trivial
amount for instance they use vitamin C
for one group and of course the RDA or
recommended daily allowance for vitamin
C is 60 milligrams double that's gonna
be 120 milligrams you can't go into a
health food store and find a vitamin C
tablet or capsule for less than 500
milligrams for an adult
and of course Lana's Pauling the
gentleman with two Nobel prizes says if
you want to prevent and treat cancer
with vitamin C you got to use 10 000
milligrams a day well all the doctors he
used to argue with him back 35 years ago
were all dead and today Lance pauling's
still 94 and he works 14 hours a day
seven days a week on his Ranch in the
Big Sur in California and teaches at the
University of California San Francisco
so you have to make up your choice
whether you're going to listen to the
Dead Doctors or Linus Pauling your
choice okay vitamin C wrda nothing
happened vitamin A Double the RDA
nothing happens zinc riboflavin the
trace mineral molybdenum nice and
nothing happened in one group they got a
major benefit in this group they got
three nutrients at one time they got
vitamin E they got beta-carotene and the
trace mineral selenium those three were
double the RDA and if you get a half a
percent benefit in any nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment you've made a
major Improvement in Humanity's life and
so these articles get published so I
want you to remember that statistic a
half a percent is major benefit well in
this group that received the vitamin E
beta-carotene and selenium for five
years deaths from all causes were
reduced by nine percent almost 10 out of
every 100 or 1 out of every 10 who were
going to die in that five years from any
cause survived
then cancers all cancers 13 survived who
would have died without those three
nutrients
so 13 out of 100 lived who would have
died and then the type of cancer that
was most prevalent in hinan Province
stomach and esophageal cancer 21 lived
who would have died 21 out of 100 lived
now to me those are significant numbers
and your physician for the number two
cause of death in America should have
sent every one of you a photocopy that
at least given the information even if
he didn't want to give you the advice
give you the information let you make up
your own mind
well here's one I think is funny on one
hand and on the other side it tells you
the attitude of Physicians this has to
do with arthritis it was in September
24th 1993 that it was released again it
was from the Harvard Medical School in
the Boston VA Hospital how many of you
in here have ever been to a VA Hospital
anybody in this room okay good well you
know the people who've been to a VA
hospital we have two opportunities to
give your life for your country once on
the field of battle and the others in
the VA Hospital right
well anyway the title of the release was
chicken protein halts the swelling and
pain of arthritis in a patient trial and
what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis these people got
gold shots mesotrexate they got aspirin
prednisone cortisone everything else you
can think of physical therapy and the
only thing left for them was joint
replacement surgery
okay now before Harvard Medical School
the VA hospital was going to give it to
him they said look we're looking for
some people who are willing to suffer
for 90 more days just three months
because we want to try something a
short-term experiment and they got 29
volunteers and what they did for those
29 volunteers who failed to respond in
any way to medical treatment for
arthritis was they gave them a heaping
teaspoon full of ground up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken cartilage and in 10
days according to Harvard Medical School
all the pain and inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical treatment
in 30 days they could open up a new
pickle jar that never been opened
and 90 days three months
they had maximum return of function
here's the funny part the funny part
comes by a statement of the guy who was
the director of that study from Harvard
Medical School and here's what he said
quote listen to the words very important
quote after three months it was clear
that the drug was beneficial unquote
because it worked chicken cartilage had
become a drug
you can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and
you can just see him calculating right
that means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones you're practicing
medicine without a license
and if you go to a Kentucky Fried
Chicken in the middle of the night in
the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the microwave
you know
you're manufacturing a pharmaceutical
and the FDA is going to put you in jail
next time I come by here in three months
you're gonna run up on this stage and
hug me and kiss me if you got arthritis
how many have ever heard of Alzheimer's
disease everybody's heard about it today
50 years ago when I was a little kid
there's no such thing as Alzheimer's
disease it's a new disease one of those
things that just sort of happened now
it's a major disease one out of every
two people who reach age 70 get
Alzheimer's disease pretty scary we
learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages Alzheimer's disease and
livestock imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their heads saying why
am I here
foreign
box because if they're not gaining a
couple of pounds a day you're losing
money right so we learned in the
agricultural industry how to prevent in
the early stages cure Alzheimer's
disease and we do it with high doses of
vitamin E and low intakes of vegetable
oil you say well like that's crazy high
doses of vitamin E well you should have
got a recall notice from your doctor in
July of 1992 because the University of
California I mean we're talking about
sophisticated research medical school
here University of California San Diego
came out and said vitamin E eases memory
loss and Alzheimer's victims now they're
only 50 years behind on that from
veterinary medicine so it might be safer
going to a veterinarian
then how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone okay I see a few
in here what's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally when
you got your kidney stone
give up calcium no Dairy no Dairy none
of those vitamin mineral things with
calcium in them because they have the
stupid naive ignorant belief that's
pretty intense they have the stupid
ignorant naive beliefs that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat when in fact it comes
from your own bones when you have a
raging Calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones and livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more Boron
now the reason is of course bulls and
rams male cattle and sheep have special
Anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they're called water belly they
die when you and I get a kidney stone we
just wish we were dead
but no Farmers dumb enough to pay for
the feed for an animal and have it die
before you can either eat it or send it
to Market so we learn how to prevent
those things well you should have got a
recall notice from your doctor
especially you people who've had kidney
stones your urologists should have sent
a notice to you
this was uh March of 1993 it says
calcium limits kidney stone risk and
this is from the Harvard Medical School
up in Boston by the way
in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones and studying
more than 45 000 people who were ranked
into five categories the group that had
the most calcium had no kidney stones
now about five years ago when I started
out on this Crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one time zone in the next and
all over I knew I was going to get crazy
out there
doing this last year I was on the road
300 days out of the Year 300 out of 365
days and so I decided I needed to have a
hobby that I could take with me every
time I get a little wacko I could go in
my room and do this Hobby and I'd be
okay you know it'd be kind of like
having a little piece of home with me
wherever I went I wanted to have a hobby
that would uh help other people I didn't
want to collect baseball cards because I
like football and I didn't want to do
just crossword puzzles because good
mental exercise but wouldn't help
anybody else and I couldn't take my
compost pile I like to garden and the
hotels don't like that you know
so I decided I was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and lawyers
what's crazy is that sounds remember I
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58 and we lived to 75.5 and
here's a group of people professionals
who pontificate you and tell you well
this is what you need to do you need to
give up salt and no caffeine and you
need to not eat butter and eat margarine
and do all these crazy things and they
die at age 58 on the average and anyway
got a few of them here are some of my
favorites so this is Dr Stuart
Cartwright age 38 he dropped dead in his
home he was a family practitioner of a
ruptured aneurysm that's a ballooning of
an artery that's a weakened artery
because of the fragmenting or the
brittle condition of the elastic fibers
and arteries just like when you hit a
Chuck hole with your car tire and you
break the cords in there and you get a
balloon
he dropped dead like he was pull axed
okay right in his home from a ruptured
aneurysm now we learned in 19 oh I think
it was 57
aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
turkeys we made complete food pellets
where you put all the 90 nutrients in
there and in the first 13 weeks fully
half of those turkeys died farmers were
out there every morning picking them up
by the bushel basket they took them to
the state diagnostic labs and they're
autopsy and they found out that they all
had died from a ruptured aortic aneurysm
so they doubled the amount of copper in
there and the next year they didn't lose
a single turkey from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm and they ran that experiment in
mice and rats and rabbits and dogs and
cats and calves and sheep and pigs and
whatnot and guess what they found out
there's a whole series of diseases that
are caused by copper deficiency gray
hair is the first sign we started
getting gray hair regardless of your age
you got a copper deficiency you get skin
wrinkles because the elastic fibers in
your skin are going those little crow's
feet around your eyes and facial and
body skin wrinkles you look like you're
a little pruned drying up
okay
then of course there's the varicose
veins
that's caused by an elastic fiber
breakdown then of course parts of your
body begin to Sag under your arms your
breasts your bellies your legs all this
stuff starts sagging and you can go to a
cosmetic surgeon or plastic surgeon if
you want but it's a lot cheaper and a
lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some copper Dr Cartwright
may have had a medical degree but he
didn't have expensive urine so he died
of something that even a turkey wouldn't
die from
then here's one this fellow he was a
doctor's doctor Dr Martin Carter he
almost made it he died at age 57. he got
his medical degree from Harvard Medical
School and his PhD in medicine from Yale
he was autopsied by the best because he
was a doctor's Doctor Who said quote the
cause of death was a ruptured aortic
aneurysm said Dr Jules Hirsch the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either and here's an attorney she was so
famous she was from Detroit age 44 Ellen
Joyce alter she was in the New York
Times obituary she made the big time and
of course she probably had steel buns
because she belonged to one of those
private health clubs all these gals won
steel buns you know doing their little
exercises
but she didn't have expensive urine
because she died of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm
when they don't do an autopsy the
symptoms could be called a stroke or a
subdural Hemorrhage but very frequently
they're caused by a ruptured aneurysm
which is a copper deficiency she didn't
have expensive urine how many of you
here have ever heard of a guy by the
name of Stuart Berger Stuart Berger he
he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from Tufts Medical
School which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
Harvard Medical School and the books he
wrote included the Southampton diet for
weight loss he wrote Forever Young 20
years younger in 20 weeks and how to be
your own nutritionist and he died at age
40. how'd you like to follow his dietary
practices he died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency the same causes white muscle
disease or or stiff lamb disease and any
farmer can go to a feed store and get
selenium pellets or selenium injections
things like celotoc and Bosey and so
forth
and Dr Stuart Berger a guy who wrote
five best-selling books on nutrition
died of a nutritional deficiency he
didn't have expensive urine you can
prevent totally prevent cardiomyopathy
for 10 cents a day and if we don't do it
we're malignant dumb I like to call it
your malignant dumb if you don't take in
10 cents a day worth of selenium it's a
waste of your life that's one of those
land mines you can avoid the medical
treatment of choice for cardiomyopathy
is a heart transplant because 750
thousand dollars I want you to think
about that they get the heart free from
a donor they get the blood free for the
surgery from the relatives
they use two dollars and fifty cents
worth of suture material
and they charge a seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for that
procedure now six months ago in La when
they had the earthquake they were
putting people in jail for 60 and 90
days for price gouging for selling these
terrified people a gallon of water for
four dollars
they put them in jail for price gouging
for selling them a gallon of water for
four bucks now to me that's
entrepreneurialism you know that's being
in business for yourself if you had a
way to distill water and make water and
you had a car and you could get in there
and sell those people a gallon of water
for four bucks hey more power to you
because if you go to a 7-Eleven and buy
a quart of Evian water it's a dollar
twenty nine
so four of those quartz is it five bucks
[Music]
and Mrs America Pageant systems and I'd
like to welcome you to the world of Dr
Joel Wallach I'm one of many who has
been gifted with restored Health as a
result of Dr wallach's research and
nutritional products Millions have heard
his message of health and long life
others have heard his message of
nutrition and Longevity from his
syndicated radio show his books are his
300 plus speaking engagements per year
listen closely and prepare to achieve
your ultimate in good health it is my
privilege to introduce researcher author
lecturer and world-renowned Authority on
Health and Longevity Dr Joel Wallace
how many of you grew up on a farm or
still work a farm or have anything to do
with livestock well I'll tell you what
you're my kind of people because I grew
up on a farm in West St Louis County and
as we started out with beef calves and
if you raise livestock the only way you
can make money is if you raise a lot of
your own feed for those of you don't
have that experience and so we raised
our own corn and we raised our own
soybeans in our own hay
and we had a truck come out from the
mill and this truck would come out from
the mill and it would grind up the corn
and the soybeans and the hay and then we
would add sacks of vitamins minerals
trace minerals and we'd make pellets out
of it and this is what we would feed the
calves in six months time we'd ship them
to Market to be slaughtered we'd save
back some of the best ones for herself
we'd knock them in the head and eat them
put it bluntly and it always fascinated
me as a teenager that we did that for
those calves and in six months ship them
off to be slaughtered or we'd eat them
and we wanted to live to be a hundred
years of age without any aches and pains
and guess what we didn't take any
vitamins or minerals
and that bothered me so I asked my dad
I'd say hey Pops how come you do that
for those calves you don't do that for
us and he'd give me this good old
Missouri farm wisdom he'd say things
like shut up boy you're getting this
farm fresh food and we hope you
appreciate it
and of course I was very quiet then
because I didn't want to miss out on any
meals well then when I went to school I
went to the University of Missouri
school of Agriculture and I got my
degree in agriculture I got my major and
animal husbandry in nutrition my minor
was in field crops and soils and then I
got into veterinary school
as a freshman Veterinary student I've
learned the answer to my question
and the answer is this we know how to
prevent and cure diseases in animals
with nutrition and the reason why we do
that is because we don't have major
medical we don't have hospitalization
Blue Cross Blue Shield we don't have
Medicare
if you're going to make money as a
farmer you better know how to do stuff
yourself and you better do it
efficiently with feed and nutrition if
you can
to make a long story short after I got
out of veterinary school I went to
Africa for two years and I was able to
fulfill a Boyhood dream I was able to be
a Frank Buck for two years and work with
Marlon Perkins many of you will remember
him from the Mutual of Omaha's Wild
Kingdom and he's a great gentleman and
after two years of working with
elephants and rhino people used to ask
me or are you a small animal vet or a
large animal vet well I was telling them
I'm an extra large animal vet because I
worked with elephants and rhinos well
after two years he sent me a telegram
and said would you come back to the St
Louis Zoo and work with us we need a
Wildlife veterinarian at the zoo for a
special project we were given a seven
and a half million dollar Grant from the
National Institutes of Health and what
we need is a veterinarian who will do
autopsies of animals that die of natural
causes in the zoo I was just Overjoyed
to do that and so I came back and and of
course I not only did autopsies for
animals that died in the St Louis Zoo
but the Brookfield Zoo in Chicago the
Bronx Zoo New York the National Zoo the
LA Zoo and so forth and my job again was
to do autopsies of animals that died of
natural causes in the zoo and look for a
species of animals that was Ultra
sensitive to pollution
this is because during the early 60s we
had just learned about pollution and
ecological problems and disasters and
nobody quite knew what to do and so I
was supposed to find a species of
animals that was extra sensitive and
used them much like we did the canaries
in the mine you know the old Welsh coal
miners used to put a canary in a little
wicker cage and take it down in the mine
and if methane gas or carbon monoxide
would leak into the mine the canary
would drop off the perch and die first
and the men knew to get out before the
mine blew up or are they suffocated
again to make a long story short over a
period of some 12 years I did 17 500
autopsies and over 454 species of
animals and 3 000 human beings who lived
in close proximity to zoos and the thing
that I found out was this every animal
and human being who dies of natural
causes dies of a nutritional deficiency
and that fascinated me it went back took
me back to those calves I said Gee
that's fascinating we could document
this at autopsy both chemically and
biochemically and things you saw with
the eye at the autopsy table well that
fascinated me and I wrote scientific
articles I wrote eight multi-author
textbooks and one textbook of my own
cost 140 bucks for medical students and
I'm sure the only thing they do is use
them for door stops
and it couldn't get anybody excited I
was on 2020
I was on 1700 newspapers
I was in magazines I was in every
Network TV that you can think of and
guess what couldn't get anybody excited
back in the 60s about nutrition
so what I did was went back to school
and became a physician to use everything
I had learned in veterinary school about
nutrition and my human patients and to
no surprise to me it worked I spent 12
years up in Portland Oregon in general
practice and it was very fascinating
what I'm going to share with you tonight
is what I learned over those 10 12 years
using nutrition with my human patients
and if you take home only 10 percent it
will save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery it will save you a
Gob of money and those of you in
Missouri know what that means that God
means a lot
okay it'll add many healthful years to
your life
well you can't do this you can't get
these healthful years you can't have
longevity you can't live to your genetic
potential just falling off a stump you
have to do some things the first thing I
have to do is convince you that it is
worth doing these things I'm going to
start out by convincing you that the
genetic potential for human beings is
120 years our genetic potential for
longevity in May 11th the oldest living
American at this time and documented
through the Guinness World Book of
Records was Margaret skeet she was from
Radford Virginia she died at age 115 and
she died of a nutritional deficiency you
can tell that from her her obituary
now she died of the complications of a
fall what does she die from osteoporosis
very good she died of a Calcium
deficiency she had no heart disease no
cancer no diabetes no other infirmities
but she died three weeks after a fall
because she didn't have enough calcium
her daughter said that she had a craving
for sweets until she died and that's a
disease called Pica we'll talk about
that in a little bit but usually when
you have a craving for chocolate if
you're a chocoholic or a sugar-a-holic
that means that you have a deficiency
then in a third world country in Niger
and Africa a chief by the name of Bauer
at age 126 was eulogized by one of his
wives and she was bragging about him at
his death at age 126. he was still in
possession of all his own teeth okay so
you assume that other faculties are
working too
then here's a gentleman from Syria at
age 133 he died in July of 1993. he
fathered nine children after the age of
80 and this meant if you add up nine
months for each child and a year for
breastfeeding for each one and a year
between each one of the children he was
still fathering children after age of a
hundred so there's still hope for you
fellas
then those of you who like science in
November of 1993 those six biosperians
came out of that dome in Arizona they
were in there for two years three
couples and they were supposed to eat
the perfect food and recycle the
atmosphere and grow their own food and
whatnot and have no pollution in their
water or air or food and when they came
out they were examined by medical
gerontologists from UCLA University of
California Los Angeles they put all this
information their physical and their
blood work and so forth into the medical
computers at UCLA and the medical
computers projected that they could live
to be 165 years old if they continued to
do what they were doing so all of that
just says to you that there's a there's
a possibility you can live to be 120 and
when I grew up on the farm we could grow
200 bushels of corn per acre and with
all the labor and all the fertilizer and
everything else you did
you could make a profit if you grew 200
bushels per acre but if you only got a
hundred bushels per acre and put out
that same effort in the same fertilizer
cause you'd lose money
and so I want you to think about it the
average lifespan for an American today
is 75.5
the average lifespan for an MD or a
doctor is 58.
you want to gain 20 years statistically
just don't go to medical school
you want to live to be 120 there's only
two basic things it's real simple two
things to remember number one you have
to avoid the pitfalls you have to not
step on the land mines I call it and
those of you in the military you know
what that means you do something stupid
like step on one of those things you
kill yourself wastefully or
unnecessarily and of course if you play
Russian Roulette or smoke excessively or
drink excessively or wear a black
sweatsuit and run down the middle of the
highway at two o'clock in the morning
you're going to get struck by a car all
of those things are foolhardy but it's
amazing how many tens of thousands of
people die in America from doing those
stupid things every year the last thing
I will share with you on that subject of
avoiding the landmines I'd suggest very
strongly to you that you avoid going to
doctors and I'm going to back up that
statement which is a pretty strong
statement from Ralph Nader's group in
January of 1993 just about a year and a
half ago January 13th he put out a news
release based on a three-year study on
the causes of death in American
hospitals and it was 1500 age report
this three-year study and I'm not going
to waste your time or Mine by going over
the whole thing word for word but the
bottom line says a lot quote 300 000
Americans are killed each year and
hospitals alone as a result of medical
negligence unquote I'm going to read
that figure again because it's a huge
figure quote 300 000 Americans are
killed each year in hospitals alone as a
result of medical negligence unquote he
didn't say Slipped Away quietly out of
neglect in a Conor somewhere while
they're waiting for an x-ray he is the
word killed when you use the word killed
that means there was a procedure the
doctor was doing went wrong somehow it
means that they gave them a wrong
prescription they put a decimal point in
the wrong spot and gave them an
incorrect dosage these people were
killed
three hundred thousand to appreciate how
big a figure that is you have to compare
that with our military losses in Vietnam
over 10 years where we lost 56 000
people over 10 years or an average of
only five thousand six hundred a year
on a field of battle where people had
guns and artillery and explosives trying
to kill each other and millions of
people poured out into the streets and
protested that war we had political
Anarchy in the last three years of the
war students took over universities and
colleges with guns and explosives
National Guardsmen shot students at Kent
State in Ohio
we chased a president out of the
presidency for 5 600 military personnel
a year and here's one profession that
takes your tax money
in the form of Medicare and Medicaid and
kills 300 000 of us a year according to
Ralph Nader and I believe him he has no
ax to grind
and you can go out in the street any day
of the week in any City and there isn't
even a crazy Street Preacher out there
with a sign that says protect us from
doctors
I want you to think about that folks
that's number one you have to avoid
stepping on the land mine so there's a
certain value in treating yourself when
you can or preventing disease they don't
have to get treated now the second thing
you have to do number two is you have to
do the positive things you have to do
the positive things and I'm going to
start out here by just putting a figure
up on the board it's the number 90 and
you need 90 nutrients in your diet every
day you need 60 minerals you need 16
vitamins you need 12 essential amino
acids or protein building blocks and you
need three essential fatty acids you
need 90 nutrients in your daily diet
otherwise you're going to get a
deficiency disease if you don't have
them in complete numbers and optimal
amounts
I can tell you that I was one of those
nerds back when I was in college I had a
clipboard we didn't have computers back
then so I had a clipboard and I was one
of those funny guys with glasses and
would walk up and down in the Student
Union there in Columbia and say do you
take vitamins and minerals I was still
fascinated by that and and of course
people kind of look at you crazy and say
well yeah I take vitamin E
and I'd wait for him to come up with the
other 89 and they didn't they just oh I
take vitamin E well today if you ask
people do you take food supplements they
say oh yeah I take Tums
because that's what you know they hear
all the time well again you need 90
nutrients if you're going to make it but
the newspaper is no and the magazines
and TV and radio knows that we're
interested in Health and Longevity and
and supplements so they all talk to us
not because the medical profession has
asked them to do that in their stead the
medical profession doesn't say hey we're
so busy saving people with surgery and
chemotherapy and radiation and
pharmaceuticals would you please educate
the people on nutrition they do it
because it sells newspapers well my
favorite article of all time appeared in
Time Magazine April 6 1992 and if you
haven't read it I'd urge you to get it
out of a school library or public
library and photocopy it stick one copy
on the door in the bathroom and one on
the refrigerator to cover article and it
says the real power of vitamins new
research shows they may help fight
cancer heart disease and the ravages of
Aging again there's six positive pages
in here there's only one negative
sentence and was issued by a medical
doctor who was asked by the writer of
the article what do you think what do
you think about vitamins and mineral for
people is food supplements and here's
what the doctor said quote popping
vitamins doesn't do you any good sniffs
Dr Victor Herbert a professor of
medicine at New York City's Mount Sinai
Medical School we get all the vitamins
we need in our diets and taking
supplements just gives you expensive
urine unquote well to give you a
Missouri translation of that that means
you're just peeing away your dollars if
you take vitamins and minerals you might
as well wad up your dollars and throw
them in the toilet and flush them away
because you're not getting any redeeming
value from it those quacks are just
taking your money for those vitamins and
minerals that's what he was trying to
say got published
so it must be true right
after having done those seventeen
thousand five hundred autopsies and 454
species of animals from around the world
and 3 000 humans and liking to be
healthy myself and having children and
grandchildren in the not too distant
future children I'd rather pee out 50
cents or a dollar a day worth of excess
vitamins and minerals it's pretty cheap
insurance
if you don't invest in yourself to the
tune of a buck a day for vitamins and
minerals guess what you're going to
invest in the lifestyle of an MD
somewhere because when you pay the
medical doctor your fee for going to see
him
not one penny of that goes to study how
to diagnose or treat or prevent a
catastrophic disease in a little child
like who was in here earlier are how to
prevent or diagnose or treat better
breast cancer prostate cancer in adults
guess what that money goes for pays a
doctor's mortgage makes his Mercedes
payment
it pays a tuition for his kids to go to
medical school at have it you know have
it is up in Boston pays a tuition for
his kids to go to law school at Yale
between 1776 and the Second World War
the U.S government spent 80 million
dollars on health care and Health Care
research and studies right now we're
1.2 trillion dollars a year for health
care
and it's free
we all know it's free right
it's not free but we're supposed to
believe it's free and everybody wants
more of it and more free stuff well I'll
tell you what if we used a human type
medical system for the agricultural
industry and the livestock your
hamburger costs 275 dollars a pound
on the other hand if you use the
agricultural health system that we use
in animals for humans your monthly
insurance premiums for a family of five
would be ten dollars a month
you take your choice
well I believe since we've made them
wealthy through Insurance programs and
government subsidies I believe they owe
us something I believe they owe us at
least as much as the industries do
according to for instance recall notices
this was started of course I don't know
25 years ago when Ralph Nader learned
that the Ford Motor Company had made a
pinto car with a rear-end gas tank that
would blow up when you got hit from
behind at 20 miles an hour fry everybody
in the car and when people complained to
Ford Motor Company they said well you're
just dumb for getting in a car accident
we're not going to pay you for that
Ralph Nader says no it's a faulty design
so he went to a federal court and the
judge agreed with them and through a
court order Forrest Ford Motor Company
to send everybody a recall notice with a
registered letter bring that car in and
they'll fix it for nothing but they kill
300 000 a year and nobody protests as
long as we get ours free and that scares
me that attitude at any rate I've got a
bunch of these recall notices you should
have gotten over the last couple years
we'll go through them quickly number one
is ulcers how many of you ever heard
that ulcers is caused by stress
okay everybody's heard that if you don't
raise your hand you got Alzheimer's or
your fibbon right
well we knew 50 years ago in in the
veterinary industry that ulcers at least
in pigs was caused by a bacteria called
helicobacter pylori and of course we
couldn't get one of these high-priced
stomach surgeons from Mayo Clinic in
fact we always used to yell hold the
Mayo when they say stuff like that
otherwise your pork chops would be 275 a
pound to pay for that kind of surgery
and we learned that with a trace mineral
called bismuth and the tetracycline
antibiotic that we could prevent and and
cure those stomach ulcers and pigs
without surgery so that's what we did
cost five bucks to cure a pig of stomach
ulcers with the Bismuth the trace
mineral and tetracycline well the
National Institutes of Health now not
the National Enquirer but the National
Institutes of Health came out in
February 1994 and said
ulcers are caused by a bacteria called
helicobacter pylori not stress
and they can be cured they actually use
the Cure word in this news release
medical researchers never do that they
always say shows promising results or
may be beneficial they use the Cure word
National Institutes of Health and they
say can be cured with a combination of
the trace mineral bismuth and
tetracycline
well for those of you don't know what
business comes in you can get it from
any grocery store or drugstore it's pink
about 295 for an eight ounce bottle and
it's called Pepto-Bismol
so a teaspoon a day full of Pepto-Bismol
and some oramycin calf scour pellets you
can take care of ulcers
now you have your choice where you're
going to treat your own for five bucks
or go get whittled on that's your choice
then what's the number two cause of
death in Americans terrible disease
called cancer right
now doctors get information on cancer
you'd think they'd photocopy that when
they send you that bill they should send
you some photocopies of this stuff well
in September of 1993 the National Cancer
Institute not the National Enquirer but
the National Cancer Institute and the
Harvard Medical School up in Boston did
a study on cancer patients and they came
out and they said an anti-cancer diet
was found
well anyway they picked China to do this
study because in one Province henan
Province in China they have the highest
rate of cancer in the whole world they
took 29 000 people for five years in
this study
and what they did was give them
different vitamins and minerals at
Double the recommended daily allowance
for Americans now that's a trivial
amount for instance they use vitamin C
for one group and of course the RDA a
recommended daily islands for vitamin C
is 60 milligrams double that's going to
be 120 milligrams you can't go into a
health food store and find a vitamin C
tablet or capsule for less than 500
milligrams for an adult
of course Lana's Pauling the gentleman
with two Nobel prizes says if you want
to prevent and treat cancer with vitamin
C you got to use 10 000 milligrams a day
well all the doctors who used to argue
with him back 35 years ago were all dead
and today Linus pauling's still 94 and
he works 14 hours a day seven days a
week on his Ranch in the Big Sur in
California and teaches at the University
of California San Francisco so you have
to make up your choice whether you're
going to listen to the Dead Doctors or
Linus Pauling your choice okay vitamin C
wrda nothing happened vitamin A Double
the RDA nothing happens zinc riboflavin
the trace mineral molybdenum nice and
nothing happened in one group they got a
major benefit in this group they got
three nutrients at one time they got
vitamin E they got beta-carotene and the
trace mineral selenium those three were
double the RDA and if you get a half a
percent benefit in any nutritional or
pharmaceutical experiment you've made a
major Improvement in Humanity's life and
so these articles get published so I
want you to remember that statistic a
half a percent is major benefit well in
this group that receives the vitamin E
beta-carotene and selenium for five
years deaths from all causes were
reduced by nine percent almost 10 out of
every 100 or 1 out of every 10 who were
going to die in that five years from any
cause survived
then cancers all cancers 13 survived who
would have died without those three
nutrients
so 13 out of 100 lived who would have
died and then the type of cancer that
was most prevalent in henan Province
stomach and esophageal cancer 21 lived
who would have died 21 out of 100 lived
now to me those are significant numbers
and your physician for the number two
cause of death in America should have
sent every one of you a photocopy that
at least given the information even if
he didn't want to give you the advice
give you the information let you make up
your own mind
well here's one I think is funny on one
hand and on the other side it tells you
the attitude of Physicians this has to
do with arthritis it was in September
24th 1993 that it was released again it
was from the Harvard Medical School in
the Boston VA Hospital how many of you
in here have ever been to a VA Hospital
anybody in this room okay good well you
know the people who've been to a VA
hospital we have two opportunities to
give your life for your country once on
the field of battle and the others in
the VA Hospital right
well anyway the title of the release was
chicken protein halts the swelling and
pain of arthritis in a patient trial and
what they did they took people who
failed to respond in any way to medical
treatment for arthritis these people got
gold shots mesotrexate they got aspirin
prednisone cortisone everything else you
can think of physical therapy and the
only thing left for them was joint
replacement surgery
okay now before Harvard Medical School
the VA hospital was going to give it to
him they said look we're looking for
some people who are willing to suffer
for 90 more days just three months
because we want to try something a
short-term experiment and they got 29
volunteers and what they did for those
29 volunteers who failed to respond in
any way to medical treatment for
arthritis was they gave them a heaping
teaspoon full of ground up dried chicken
cartilage in their orange juice every
morning just a heaping teaspoon of
ground up chicken cartilage and in 10
days according to Harvard Medical School
all the pain and inflammation was gone
these are people who didn't respond in
any way to medical treatment
in 30 days they could open up a new
pickle jar that never been opened
and 90 days three months
they had maximum return of function
here's the funny part the funny part
comes by a statement of the guy who was
the director of that study from Harvard
Medical School and here's what he said
quote listen to the words very important
quote after three months it was clear
that the drug was beneficial unquote
because it worked chicken cartilage had
become a drug
you can see he's thinking about patent
numbers and his eyes are rolling around
with 300 bucks a capsule 20 patients and
you can just see him calculating right
that means if you go to Kentucky Fried
Chicken and you buy a bucket of chicken
throw away the skin and the meat and eat
the ends off the bones you're practicing
medicine without a license
and if you go to a Kentucky Fried
Chicken in the middle of the night in
the dark of the night and you go to
their dumpster and you root through
there and you collect two five gallon
feed buckets full of chicken bones and
you take them home with a hammer and you
pound off the ends of those bones and
dry your own cartilage in the microwave
you know
your manufacturing a pharmaceutical and
the FDA is going to put you in jail next
time I come by here in three months
you're gonna run up on this stage and
hug me and kiss me if you got arthritis
how many have ever heard of Alzheimer's
disease everybody's heard about it today
50 years ago when I was a little kid
there's no such thing as Alzheimer's
disease it's a new disease one of those
things that just sort of happened now
it's a major disease one out of every
two people who reach age 70 get
Alzheimer's disease pretty scary we
learned 50 years ago in the animal
industry how to prevent and cure in the
early stages Alzheimer's disease and
livestock imagine how much a farmer
would lose if the pigs were all laying
there scratching their head saying why
am I here
where is the feed box because if they're
not gaining a couple of pounds a day
you're losing money right so we learned
in the agricultural industry how to
prevent in the early stages cure
Alzheimer's disease and we do it with
high doses of vitamin E and low intakes
of vegetable oil you say well like
that's crazy high doses of vitamin E
well you should have got a recall notice
from your doctor in July of 1992 because
the University of California I mean
we're talking about sophisticated
research medical school here University
of California San Diego came out and
said vitamin E eases memory loss and
Alzheimer's victims now they're only 50
years behind on that from veterinary
medicine so it might be safer going to a
veterinarian
then how many of you in this room ever
had a kidney stone anybody in here ever
get that kidney stone okay I see a few
in here what's the first thing a doctor
told you to give up nutritionally when
you got your kidney stone
give up calcium no Dairy no Dairy none
of those vitamin mineral things with
calcium in them because they have the
stupid naive ignorant belief that's
pretty intense they have the stupid
ignorant naive belief that the calcium
in your kidney stone comes from the
calcium you eat when in fact it comes
from your own bones when you have a
raging Calcium deficiency a raging
osteoporosis then you get kidney stones
we learned years ago in writing in the
agricultural industry if you wanted to
prevent kidney stones and livestock you
better give them more calcium you better
give them more magnesium and more Boron
the reason is of course bulls and rams
male cattle and sheep have special
Anatomy when they get a kidney stone
they die they're called water belly they
die when you and I get a kidney stone we
just wish we were dead
but no Farmers dumb enough to pay for
the feed for an animal and have it die
before you can either eat it or send it
to Market so we learned how to prevent
those things well you should have got a
recall notice from your doctor
especially you people who've had kidney
stones your urologist should have sent a
notice to you
this was March of 1993 it says calcium
limits kidney stone risk and this is
from the Harvard Medical School up in
Boston by the way
in a study that turns conventional
medical wisdom on its head researchers
have found that people whose diets are
rich in calcium run a reduced risk of
developing kidney stones in a study of
more than 45 000 people who were ranked
into five categories the group that had
the most calcium had no kidney stones
now about five years ago when I started
out on this Crusade and started
lecturing to people all across America
and I'm in one time zone in the next and
all over I knew I was going to get crazy
out there
doing this last year I was on the road
300 days out of the Year 300 out of 365
days and so I decided I needed to have a
hobby that I could take with me every
time I get a little wacko I could go in
my room and do this Hobby and I'd be
okay you know it'd be kind of like to
have a little piece of home with me
wherever I went I wanted to have a hobby
that would uh help other people I didn't
want to collect baseball cards because I
like football and I didn't want to do
just crossword puzzles because good
mental exercise but wouldn't help
anybody else and I couldn't take my
compost pile I like to garden and the
hotels don't like that you know
so I decided I was going to collect
obituaries of doctors and lawyers
what's crazy is that sounds remember I
told you the doctors lived to an average
age of 58 and we lived to 75.5 and
here's a group of people professionals
who pontificate you and tell you well
this is what you need to do you need to
give up salt and no caffeine and you
need to not eat butter and eat margarine
and do all these crazy things and they
die at age 58 on the average and anyway
got a few of them here are some of my
favorites so this is Dr Stuart
Cartwright age 38 he dropped dead in his
home he was a family practitioner of a
ruptured aneurysm that's a ballooning of
an artery that's a weakened artery
because of the fragmenting or the
brittle condition of the elastic fibers
and arteries just like when you hit a
Chuck hole with your car tire and you
break the cords in there and you get a
balloon
he dropped dead like he was pole axed
okay right in his home from a ruptured
aneurysm and we learned in 19 oh I think
it was 57
aneurysms are caused by a copper
deficiency we had a pilot project
turkeys we made complete food pellets
where you put all the 90 nutrients in
there and in the first 13 weeks fully
half of those turkeys died farmers were
out there every morning picking them up
by the bushel basket they took them to
the state diagnostic labs and they're
autopsy and they found out that they all
had died from a ruptured aortic aneurysm
so they doubled the amount of copper in
there and the next year they didn't lose
a single turkey from a ruptured aortic
aneurysm and they ran that experiment in
mice and rats and rabbits and dogs and
cats and calves and sheep and pigs and
whatnot and guess what they found out
there's a whole series of diseases that
are caused by a copper deficiency gray
hair is the first sign we started
getting gray hair regardless of your age
you got a copper deficiency you get skin
wrinkles because the elastic fibers in
your skin are going those little crow's
feet around your eyes and facial and
body skin wrinkles you look like you're
a little pruned drying up okay
then of course there's the varicose
veins
that's caused by an elastic fiber
breakdown then of course parts of your
body begin to Sag under your arms your
breasts your bellies your legs all this
stuff starts sagging and you can go to a
cosmetic surgeon or plastic surgeon if
you want but it's a lot cheaper and a
lot more effective and a lot safer if
you just take some copper Dr Cartwright
may have had a medical degree but he
didn't have expensive urine so he died
of something that even a turkey wouldn't
die from
then here's one this fellow he was a
doctor's doctor Dr Martin Carter he
almost made it he died at age 57. he got
his medical degree from Harvard Medical
School and his PhD in medicine from Yale
he was autopsied by the best because he
was a doctor's doctor he said quote the
cause of death was a ruptured aortic
aneurysm said Dr Jules Hirsch the
Rockefeller University Hospital unquote
what did he die from copper deficiency
see he didn't have expensive urine
either and here's an attorney she was so
famous she was from Detroit age 44 Ellen
Joyce alter she was in the New York
Times obituary she made the big time and
of course she probably had steel buns
because she belonged to one of those
private health clubs all these
gals won steel buns you know doing their
little exercises
but she didn't have expensive urine
because she died of a ruptured cerebral
aneurysm
when they don't do an autopsy the
symptoms could be called a stroke or a
subdural Hemorrhage but very frequently
they're caused by a ruptured aneurysm
which is a copper deficiency she didn't
have expensive urine how many of you
here have ever heard of a guy by the
name of Stuart Berger Stuart Berger he
he wrote five best-selling books on
health and diets and nutrition he got
his medical degree from Tufts Medical
School which is a very fine medical
school in Boston not too far away from
Harvard Medical School and the books he
wrote included the Southampton diet for
weight loss he wrote Forever Young 20
years younger in 20 weeks and how to be
your own nutritionist and he died at age
40. how'd you like to follow his dietary
practices he died at age 40 of
cardiomyopathy which is a selenium
deficiency the same causes white muscle
disease or or stiff lamb disease and any
farmer can go to a feed store and get
selenium pellets or selenium injections
things like cellotoc and Bosey and so
forth
and Dr Stuart Berg A guy who wrote five
best-selling books on nutrition died of
a nutritional deficiency he didn't have
expensive urine you can prevent totally
prevent
cardiomyopathy for 10 cents a day and if
we don't do it we're malignant dumb I
like to call it your malignant dumb if
you don't take in 10 cents a day worth
of selenium it's a waste of your life
that's one of those landmines you can
avoid the medical treatment of choice
for cardiomyopathy is a heart transplant
a 750 thousand dollars I want you to
think about that they get the heart free
from a donor they get the blood free for
the surgery from the relatives
they use two dollars and fifty cents
worth of suture material
and they charge a seven hundred and
fifty thousand dollars for that
procedure now six months ago in La when
they had the earthquake they were
putting people in jail for 60 and 90
days for price gouging for selling these
terrified people a gallon of water for
four dollars
they put them in jail for price gouging
for selling them a gallon of water for
four bucks
now to me that's entrepreneurialism you
know that's being in business for
yourself if you had a way to distill
water and make water and you had a car
and you could get in there and sell
those people a gallon of water for four
bucks hey more power to you because if
you go to a 7-Eleven and buy a quart of
Evian water it's a dollar twenty nine
so four of those quartz is it five bucks
kind of interesting isn't it they said
it was price gouging because those
people were terrified we'll talk about a
person who needs a new heart they're
terrified seven hundred and fifty
thousand dollars we should put those
doctors in jail but we bow to them
because oh that's high-tech medicine
out of 270 million people in America you
save about 50 a year is that cost
effective I don't think so Dr Stuart
Berger didn't have expensive urine
here's the last one and many of you may
know this woman her name is Dr Gail
Clark she was age 47 she was the chief
cardiologist of West St Louis County
Rupa hospitals she was the chief
cardiologist for the Saint Mary's Health
Center in Richmond Heights and St Louis
County she was age 47. guess what she
died from
heart attack a cardiomyopathy heart
attack you can just see her walking down
the hall she's got the stethoscope
around her neck you know this is their
little status symbol got my stethoscope
around my neck back when I was in school
they folded it up very bravely and put
it in their pocket boom she falls down
she has a heart attack right in the hall
and of course the nurses scoop her up
and put her on a gurney and they call
the technicians in another doctor code
three code three code blue whatever it
is and they whip her into the room and
you can hear him let's say you're a
cardiac patient you're laying there
you're all hooked up to the monitors and
the IVs and and you hear them say Okay
tear clothes off
okay stand back didn't work turn it up
stand back and then you hear that
terrible sound when you know that the
treatment didn't work
the flat line when you know the heart is
gone
and everybody walks out of the room
dejected and you say nurse nurse what
happened next door and she says well
your cardiologist you know the chief
cardiologist of this Hospital age 47 Dr
Gail Clark
just died of a cardiomyopathy heart
attack we can see all the patients
they're holding their gowns
and they're running out of that hospital
leaving their watches and their shoes
and their checkbooks and everything
they're plastic credit cards because
they don't want to get what Dr Gail
Clark got to me the Reader's Digest is a
magazine that never says anything
negative or bad about anybody or any
group it's the sweetest little magazine
that ever was the September 1993 issue
features an article it says can you
trust your doctor it lists 12 ways that
doctors scam your money and I'll let you
read 11 of them yourself I'll give you
the worst one in addition
to their income from Office fees and
surgical fees and lab fees and
hospitalization doctors get a kickback
from the labs and the the X-ray labs and
Clinics and hospitals they get a
kickback of 421 dollars every time they
send you in for a CAT scan or an MRI
and doctors tell you oh we do that
because we're practicing defensive
medicine because if I miss something you
know one in 10 billion you're going to
sue me so I do this just to protect
myself well if it was just to protect
themselves and you knew them and they
knew you'd 90 of the people say oh just
skip it DOC if you don't really think
it's necessarily save the money but they
got something more than defensive
medicine to worry about they get 421
bucks in a kickback for every time they
send you in for an MRI or a CAT scan
well when I practice for 12 years up in
Portland somebody come to me with a
terrible headache never had one I just
walk up to them and tap them on the
sinuses and if they'd collapse to their
knees I know they had a sinus headache
oh doc why'd you do that well I just
wanted that's a cheap lab test you know
then if they had thank you if they had
blood dripping out of their nose it'd
take a 35 x-ray to see if they had a
cancer in there
35 bucks in a free lab test as opposed
to 421 bucks if I wanted to make that
421 bucks I'd have been a good Thief
what I'd have done I had to build a
chute right into that cat scan machine
because I knew how to build shoots
living on a farm and I'd have gone out
in the street and I'd have got every
homeless person I'd line them up in them
shoots and I'd put soup in a Big Mac at
the end of that tube you know and I say
I'm going to get by you a dollar fifty
dinner I'm a good guy I'm gonna buy you
a dollar fifty dinner you just got to go
through this shoot go through that tube
and you get your sandwich and your soup
man they'd be flowing through there
maybe a hundred a day and I could start
adding some things up it'd be a lot of
fun anyway the average doctor gets 228
660 dollars a year in cat scan Kickbacks
a quarter of a million dollars a year
and any other industry if you do that
politicians lawyers
businessmen stock Brokers they get put
in jail
but doctors it's okay because insurance
pays for it we don't mind if they steal
is blind it's free remember I told you I
was going to tell you about pica
Pica is a funny disease Pica I'm not
talking about the type style that you
see in typewriters and computers but
Pike is a disease that farmers know
about in horses it's called cribbing
when they chew on the feed bunk the
wooden feed bunk
you know you better give them some
minerals otherwise they're gonna eat
that feed bunk and cattle dairy cattle
especially where they're losing lots of
minerals through their milk all the time
intensive milking you'll see them
picking up big rocks in the creek and
chewing on them or they'll chew on
barbed wire or maybe you'll see them
walking down through a path with a deer
bone in their mouth or something or a
shingle that's called Pica and a good
farmer husband dreaming knows you better
give them some minerals otherwise
they're going to eat the barn or
something
in human beings we see this at funny
times pregnant women are notorious for
Pica in the middle of the night they'll
elbow their husband and say Hey you
better get up I want some pickles and
ice cream they're craving minerals
because that fetus is pulling minerals
out of their body they need some more
minerals and so it's it's recognized as
a craving for things like sweets and
salt we see this in pregnant women I
used to have people come to my practice
and they say doctor I need to go see a
shrink I said why is that well I wake up
in the middle of the night and I go
outside with a spoon and I eat dirt and
no that's okay just make sure it's clean
dirt
then they say my kid sits there with a
kitty litter box between his legs and
has a spoon and he's eating that stuff
out of the kitty litter box
and then in housing projects little kids
will eat lead paint off the walls and
they get lead poison get learning
disabilities and Bone problems and
anemia and we're good so we spend five
million dollars to scrape the lead paint
off of there and repaint it with latex
paint and all you have to do is give
those kids 10 cents a day worth of
minerals be better for them and save us
five million bucks
it's your tax money and if we allow them
to throw them away those dollars is kind
of interesting if you have a selenium
deficiency and you don't want to wait
until you get to cardiomyopathy and drop
dead from a heart attack to recognize it
if you look on your hands and look in
the mirror on your face if you have
liver spots or age spots and I see quite
a few from here
you have an early selenium deficiency
that's called free radical damage and
fortunately for you if you recognize
that and you start taking in some
selenium in four to six months those
will go away you'll reverse that in four
to six months and when they go away on
the outside they're going away on the
inside your brain and your heart and
your liver and your kidneys and if you
have low blood sugar how many in this
room have low blood sugar anybody here
have low blood sugar okay about 10
percent how many have you ever seen a
hyperactive kid who gets on sugar okay
about everybody in the room people who
have sugar problems are like alcoholics
there's good ones and bad ones you know
the good alcoholics are one when they
get two drinks they just go off in a
corner and go to sleep right same way
with somebody with low blood sugar they
eat a big meal or they eat a piece of
pie three hours later they clunk out and
go to sleep then there's bad alcoholics
they're the one that gets two drinks in
them and they get violent and raged and
they want to fight everybody punch holes
in the wall you know big Brave fellows
and they kick their wife and kick the
dog and take the chainsaw and cut their
neighbor's tree down and all these wild
things and drive Reckless down the roads
and kill people those are bad drugs well
people who have blood sugar problems
there's bad blood sugar people too
they're a little crazy okay I don't know
how many of you remember the twinkie
defense
right remember somebody murdered two
people and he claimed he ate a Twinkie
three hours before he murdered them so
they let him off because he got
temporarily insane every time he ate
sugar now don't any of you try that
well chromium and Vanadium deficiency
will result in the sugar problems low
blood sugar and if you let it go on for
any length of time you develop diabetes
chromium and Vanadium then a tin
deficiency the early symptoms of a tin
deficiency are male pattern baldness I
see a lot of tin deficiency in this room
yes
and if you let it go on for any length
of time you get deafness then there's a
boron deficiency and you gals should
know about boron because it helps you
keep the calcium you take in in your
bones so you don't get osteoporosis
Boron also it helps you make estrogen it
helps you fellas make testosterone if
you don't take in enough Boron you
ladies are going to suffer miserably
going through menopause okay you're
going to have all those terrible
symptoms
you fellas don't get enough Boron can't
make testosterone you won't know whether
to lead or follow on the Dance Floor
you're going to be confused
she's saying he's got a boron deficiency
the first symptoms of a zinc deficiency
is you lose your sense of smell and your
taste you say oh you know food just
doesn't taste good anymore and you don't
have a cold or anything like that you
say
your wife says well aren't you excited
about dinner I spent the whole day in
the kitchen cooking dinner he said well
I didn't smell anything when I walked in
you know he's got a zinc deficiency when
laboratory animals there's some seven
rare Earths these rare Earths or trace
minerals you need in lesser amounts than
you need trace minerals and they
actually double the lifespan of
laboratory animals they've not been
proven in humans yet but I'm not going
to wait 500 years for doctors to approve
it they're still arguing over vitamin C
and calcium right so I'm just going to
do it didn't kill any laboratory animals
just doubles their life and it's not a
drug these rare Earths are called
lanthanum paraciodymium neodymium
samarium europium uterbium and thulium
there must be a reason why they're named
after Old Testament cities well remember
I told you we needed 90 nutrients we
need 60 minerals we need 16 vitamins 12
essential amino acids and three
essential fatty acids and of course
we're lucky in that plants as a group
can make most vitamins amino acids and
fatty acids plants can do that because
they just take carbon out of the air and
make carbon chains to make vitamins
amino acids and fatty acids but you have
to eat 15 to 25 different plants a day
in the right combinations to make this
happen theoretically it's possible but
most Americans don't do it the average
American thinks if they eat some potato
buds out of a Betty Crocker box or
eating a vegetable okay so you got to be
careful what you're considering a
vegetable then of course people want to
do right by their doctor and they eat
low-fat turkey breasts and they put a
half a jar of mayonnaise on there and
they put it between two slices of Wonder
styrofoam bread
remember that stuff you can insulate
your house with and put in your shoes
when you get a hole in the shoe I
remember when I was a kid it was a lot
of fun because we have Wonder Bread we
didn't have TVs back then on the farm we
didn't even have dryers that went round
and round so the only thing you could do
in the winter time was sit in the
kitchen and wondered a loaf of Wonder
Bread and it had the blue and red and
green yellow balloons on there and if
you read the labels many times as I do
you know it said things like helps build
bodies at 12 ways and about 15 years
later the FDA made him change it to help
build your body eight ways now if you go
to the store and look at Wonder Bread
wrappers it just says Wonder Bread so it
kind of gives you a clue
so even though this is theoretically
possible it's not likely to happen that
you're going to get your vitamins amino
acids and fatty acids in proper
proportions from your diet and so if
your life is as valuable to you as mine
is to me and my children's and my
grandchildren's is to me
I would make sure that I take in all my
vitamins and amino acids and fatty acids
because I guarantee you won't make it to
120 if you don't
you're just not going to do it
now minerals are another story we have a
tragic story when it comes to minerals
because
plants cannot make minerals in any way
shape or form and if they're not in the
soil anymore they're not in our plants
our farm soils and our rain soils are
depleted of minerals and the crops the
grains the fruits and the vegetables and
the nuts that are grown on these
depleted farm and Rain soils are
minimally deficient the people who eat
them get mineral deficiency diseases and
the only way to prevent and cure them is
with mineral supplements you think it's
gotten any better
no it has not gotten any better it's
only gotten worse and the reason is if
you guys do what we did and people
continue to do is we put NPK on our land
nitrogen phosphorus potassium and you
see it as these three numbers and many
combinations of ratios and these
represent percentages of these three
nutrients nitrogen phosphorus potassium
and those of you who don't have any
experience on farms the reason why we do
this is farmers get paid for tons and
bushels there's no subsidy that
encourages people to put 60 minerals
back in the soil you get paid for tons
and bushels and for 40 bucks an acre you
can get the maximum yield in tons and
bushels it only takes five to ten years
to deplete the land of minerals because
every time you harvest a crop those
plants pull minerals out of the soil
many pounds per acre every time you haul
a crop out so soon those minerals are
gone and if you only put back in three
and you take out 60 it's like a checking
account if you only put three bucks in
your checking account every month and
write checks for 60 what's going to
happen to your checks boing boing boing
they bounce exactly well I can tell you
that our health is bouncing right now to
the tune of 1.2 trillion dollars a year
it's our responsibility each and every
one of us to be responsible for our
health and consciously take in these
minerals I have a lot of people ask me
what did these people do thousands of
years ago they didn't even have
commercial fertilizers what did they do
these societies that had long-lived
people and whatnot I want you to think
about the Egyptians the Chinese people
from India that lived around these Great
Rivers the Nile River the Ganges River
the yalo river in China and what used to
happen was every year or so would flood
just like it did here in Northern
Missouri
last year and every time it flooded
guess what would happen it would bring
silt or rock dust from Mountains from
500 or 1000 miles away and those people
would pray to every God they had the
water God the sky God the wind God The
Rock God to flood we pray don't flood
they used to pray to flood because they
had their floods during the winter time
and would put silt and minerals back in
the soil and their grain was very
valuable King Philip who's the father of
Alexander the Great married the 12 year
old child queen of Egypt Cleopatra she
didn't look like Elizabeth Taylor all
made up in beautiful costumes she was a
little flat-chested teeny bopper not
very sexy but Philip married her because
she controlled the best wheat in the
world and if he wanted his Macedonian
army to conquer the world through his
son Alexander the Great he needed the
best wheat in the world so you could
March 20 hours a day fight for six hours
and win if they used the wheat from the
depleted soils in Greece they couldn't
go 20 minutes without saying mommy pick
me up can you imagine these big Greek
soldiers Oh my legs hurt pick me up
and so they knew the best place to get
wheat was from Egypt
it was those floods that gave them those
minerals and all those cultures that
came up with all the great art and all
the great technology came from those
places because they had more
intelligence because it had more
nutrition more minerals I heard somebody
say very good well you're getting the
picture well what I'm going to do here
is I'm just going to pick out a couple
of minerals just a couple of them so you
get the idea it applies to all of them
let's just pick out a common one like
calcium everybody knows about calcium
Calcium deficiency will result in
something like 147 different diseases
they're just different names they're
named after people like Bell's Palsy you
know everybody knows about that one side
of your face sags it's not as true
stroke it just affects your facial
muscles it's caused by Calcium
deficiency we'll talk about in a little
bit but everybody knows about this one
osteoporosis it's the number 10 killer
of adults in the United States it's very
expensive it costs you 35 000 each for
each hip to replace it's okay it's free
insurance will pay for it costs you
seventy thousand dollars for both hips
as expensive as it is and the number 10
killer remember
Mrs Skeets from Radford Virginia age 115
years of age he died of complications of
a fall
we don't have osteoporosis in animals
and it's because of farmers we don't
have osteoporosis and animals goes like
this you have a pasture with a hundred
cows in it and this year you didn't have
any calves you can't repay your
operating loan you're in trouble
right because you paid for the feed and
the vet bill and mowed the pasture and
fertilized and maintained the fence and
fed the cows and all this that and the
other you don't have any calves you
can't pay back the operating load and
make any money so you call the vet out
and you say do I get rid of these cows
what happened here and he examines the
cows there's nothing wrong with them
says let me look at the bull he said aha
here's your problem that bull has
osteoporosis of both hips can't breed
the cows didn't have any calves he says
I'll tell you what though he says you
give me seventy thousand dollars he says
I'll put two new hips in that bowl next
year you'll have some calves
well the first thing that farmer says is
stand back doc boom
he blows that bull away with a deer
rifle and while the kids are grinding
the bull up with a grinder and cutting
roast and steaks off that bull the
farmer is chewing on a straw and saying
now Doc pushes Stetson up a little bit
and he says you know I wasn't going to
pay you 70 000 for that old boy he said
I'd get a new bull every year for 70
years for that he says but every once in
a while I get a bullet throws good
calves I'd like to keep them is there
any way I can prevent that osteoporosis
thing for happening to a good bull he
says well yeah he says if you'll give a
bull calf 10 cents worth of calcium
every day after he's weaned he'll never
get osteoporosis first and wait a minute
doc you mean if I give that bull 10
cents a day worth of calcium from the
time he's weaned I can prevent a seventy
thousand dollar disaster oh yeah it's
that simple he says you mean all they
have to do is give up a half a cup of
coffee a day to do that he says yeah
that's it he says I choose that one he
said I'll give up the half a cup of
coffee and that's what we have to think
like then there's receding gums dentist
and periodontists will tell you that if
you want to prevent and cure receding
gums you better floss and brush after
every meal if you believe that works I
have some oceanfront property in Montana
to sell you
if you all know your geography you know
that doesn't work now as a veterinarian
I've seen hundreds of thousands of
animals of all kinds mice rats rabbits
dogs cats sheep pigs horses lions and
tigers and bears and they don't get
receding gums
and they don't floss now they do get
funky breath but they don't get receding
gums well if you want to smell something
you just let a camel breathe on you boy
well the reason we don't have receding
gums and livestock is because we've
dealt with the osteoporosis problem
receding gums is not a deficiency of
flossing it's in fact osteoporosis of
the jaw bones and of the facial bones so
if you have gingivitis or receding gums
you have advanced osteoporosis those
bones around your teeth are melting away
a little bit by a little bit every day
and if you take your teeth out at night
and put them in a glass next to your bed
and that fizzy stuff you have major
advanced osteoporosis because all your
bone has melted away
then there's arthritis we talked about
that a little bit earlier remember the
chicken cartilage 85 percent of all
arthritis is caused by osteoporosis of
the joint ends of the bones you're
talking about degenerative arthritis
osteoarthritis sciatica lumbago
rheumatism all those sorts of things
they're caused by osteoporosis so the
joint ends of the bones I want you to
think about something for a minute if
you don't take a pain reliever or an
anti-inflammatory for that arthritis
let's say you get arthritis of the hips
you're going to kind of favor that a
little bit aren't you you're going to
get a cane or a walker or crutches
you're going to favor it so you don't
put any weight on it I want you to think
about that for just a second because
then I want you to think about driving
your tractor in a field or you're
driving a Mercedes down the highway
either one doesn't matter whichever you
love more
let's say you didn't put the nut on that
oil pan real tighten all the oil drained
out and that light on the dashboard
comes on says I'm getting hot you better
give me some oil and that light
irritates you so you stop you open up
the hood you get your clippers out you
know your fence Clippers and you clip
the wire to that light you close the
hood and you just keep driving
would you do that to your tractor or
your Mercedes no you wouldn't
but we take those pain relievers for
arthritis and we go out there and square
dance and do the Texas Two Step and do
our five mile walks in our aerobics that
pill Works real good doc because it
killed my pain and you're just wearing
that thing off faster and faster then
your doctor is really going to get rich
because you need joint replacement
surgery then there's hypertension this
is one of my favorites so I'll put a
star over here hypertension is high
blood pressure what's the first
nutritional thing that a doctor will
tell you to give up nutritionally when
you get high blood pressure give up salt
everybody knows that one that's been
ingrained in our head well they must
think we're dumber than cows because
what's the first thing you put out for
your livestock is about that big a salt
block no farmer is going to be
economically viable if you don't put a
salt block out for your livestock
they're going to die kind of your
Veterinary bills are going to go crazy
but we're supposed to believe that we
don't need salt you can get everything
you need out of your lettuce and your
whole wheat bread and stuff like that
well don't believe that one either if
you believe that I got some more
oceanfront property in Montana for you
they took 30 million dollars tax money
and two years ago after 20-year study
they came out and said that they took
five thousand people with high blood
pressure they took them off their
medication and put them on a reduced
salt diet a restricted salt diet and
they all died no big surprise but
somebody got a PhD degree and everybody
was happy right
but when they looked at this results
they said that oh only 99.7 percent of
the people didn't get any results from
that before they died 0.3 percent did
get some results dropped their blood
pressure one point before they died by
restricting their salt so the referees
who judged that article said oh doesn't
matter you might as well let high blood
pressure patients eat salted peanuts and
dill pickles and salt their food to
taste because it doesn't matter in fact
worrying about the salt is more stress
than taking the salt then they had a
control group with five thousand people
with high blood pressure and they
doubled their RDA of calcium and they
stopped the experiment in six weeks
because 85 percent of them were cured to
their high blood pressure just by
doubling their calcium intake now they
didn't cold turkey stop their high blood
pressure medication but what they did
was they went to the doctor and says you
don't need this medication anymore
what are you doing I said well I'm on
this experiment where I double my
calcium intake anybody get a recall
notice from your doctor saying it's okay
to Salt your food to taste and please do
double your calcium intake anybody get
that not a single one that's very
interesting then of course there's
insomnia that's where you roll around
all night you wake up in the morning
you're more tired when you went to bed
that's insomnia of course doctors have
two treatments for that they have
Halcyon which is a sleeping pill and
they have barbiturates they kill about
10 000 people a year with overdoses of
those things but that's okay isn't
prescription and they're watching out
for us and remember George Bush when he
went to Japan they gave him some Halcyon
so he could sleep on the way to Japan
because of the time difference and when
he woke up one of the side effects of
Halcyon is nausea and vomiting
say it in Japanese but it was very
dramatic on world TV right not very
presidential
and so I'm sure that's why he lost the
election because he puked over that
Japanese ambassador
and then of course there's kidney stones
and then there's a bone spurs heel spurs
and calcium deposits again Physicians
will tell you the first thing to give up
nutritionally is calcium and dairy
because they have this foolish belief
the stupid belief the ignorant belief
that the calcium in kidney stones bone
spurs heel spurs and calcium deposits
come from your diet when instead it only
comes from your bones when you have a
raging osteoporosis and when you get
these things you need more calcium not
less then there's cramps and Twitches
you wake up in the middle of the night
and your foot is all cramped up around
your neck you say Lord take me from the
knee down I'm not going to make it till
morning we've all experienced that
that's very common
then there's PMS premenstrual syndrome
you know the emotional and physical
stuff the medical treatment of choice
for PMS is what we call a hysterical
ectomy it's been shortened to
hysterectomy that's a 100 year old
treatment that doctors do about 285 000
unnecessary hysterical ectomies a year
but it makes Mercedes payments so they
do them even the AMA said they're
unnecessary but they don't take their
licenses away and people keep going to
them you imagine a poor woman in her 30s
she says doc you got to do something
every time I go out to hang up the
clothes my neighbors kids run down the
basement screaming which my own kids
think I'm crazy my husband's leaving me
I'm gonna lose my job you got to do
something well the University of
California San Diego came out three
years ago now and said if you just
double the RDA of calcium intake you get
rid of 85 percent of the emotional and
physical symptoms of PMs and when that
came out there were huge lines around
the health food stores around the blocks
and people had sleeping bags because
they closed before they all got their
calcium and every person in line was a
man
they were there for their daughters and
their girlfriends and their wives and
things like that okay and lastly is low
back pain 85 percent of Americans get
low back pain whether you work on a
computer or you unload hay or you drive
big trucks doesn't matter low back is a
big problem low back is just
osteoporosis of the vertebrae whether
you have a disc problem or whatnot
because if your disc doesn't have
anything to hold on to your vertebrae
melted away what's going to happen to
the disc especially if you have a copper
deficiency because they're made out of
elastic fibers they go like a water
balloon with a lot of pressure on them I
just want you to look at this quickly
before we do the last mineral low back
you go to an orthopedic surgeon or
rheumatologist you might get a muscle
relaxant you might get valium and a
muscle relaxant you get a laminectomy
you get your vertebrae fuse you might
get a disc operation they don't tell you
75 percent of the time you'll never be
the same again
right PMS you go to your OB GYN you can
go to an internist you can go to a
family counselor a shrink or divorce
attorney cramps and Twitches you go to a
neurologist you go to a sports medicine
doctor an internist bone spurs heel
spurs calcium deposits you go to a
rheumatologist an orthopedic surgeon or
a podiatrist kidney stones you go to a
urologist or an internist or a surgeon
insomnia go to a shrinker a Sleep Clinic
or an internist hypertension you go to a
Cardiologist an internist or a surgeon
arthritis a rheumatologist a orthopedic
surgeon or an internist receding gums
you go to a dentist or a periodontist
osteoporosis you go to all those Health
Specialists including a tum salesman
for nothing more than a Calcium
deficiency would cost you 10 cents a day
to deal with now on the average because
Americans have insurance and we have
Medicare and Medicaid we spend on the
average 25
000 to 250 000 and we undergo five to
ten surgical procedures a year for a
Calcium deficiency we beg the doctors to
do it we beg the doctors to do it well
it's our choice the last one I'll share
with you is diabetes everybody's touched
by diabetes it's the number three cause
of death in adults in the United States
number three cause of death and it has
terrible complications and side effects
diabetes the side effects include
blindness of many kinds then there's a
kidney failure with dialysis and kidney
transplant there's cardiovascular
disease of all kinds and of course that
contributes the number one cause of
death then there is amputations
everybody ought to have one of those
because they're totally paid for in
their health thing because they assume
that you're not just going to get one
because you want to get everything on
your health benefits and then you
shorten your life because if you have
diabetes on the average you have a
shorter lifespan than someone who
doesn't have diabetes now we learned in
1957 in the animal industry that we
could prevent and cure diabetes with two
trace minerals that's a pretty profound
statement that we could prevent and cure
diabetes with two trace minerals in 1957
and animals it was published in
Federation proceedings which is the
official Journal of the American Science
the National Institutes of Health the
official monthly Journal is August 1957.
well the two trace minerals that you can
get to prevent and cure this are
chromium and Vanadium Vanadium alone
according to the University of Vancouver
British Columbia Medical School Vanadium
alone will replace insulin in adult
onset diabetics which represent 85
percent of all diabetics of course they
can't quit their insulin cold turkey
they've got to gradually wean off of it
takes four to six months for most people
to slowly wean off of insulin if they're
taking in adequate amount of chromium
and Vanadium now to me this is Criminal
because if you write to Hills packing
company that makes signs dot dog food
right over here in Topeka Kansas so they
manufacture Science Diet dog food and
other Science Diet product high-tech
foods for animals
if you write them and say how many
minerals exactly is in Science Diet for
dog food they'll write you back and say
there's 40 minerals
you're right checkerboard Square in St
Louis Ross and pray and say just how
many minerals are in your wrap pellets
for laboratory rats and they'll say
there's 28 minerals I'll give anybody in
this room a Chris new hundred dollar
bill if you can find me a human infant
formula in a grocery store that has more
than 11. so our dogs get 40 minerals
remember that's what Mike Murphy was
saying his dog never seems to get sick
because he's getting this canned dog
food with all these vitamins and
minerals in there so our dogs get 40
minerals our rats get 28 minerals and
our human infants get 11. is that fair
no that's called fraud
doesn't matter if you're talking about
SMA Similac Isomil Pro soy B in fact
that's why they call Similac Similac
because it lacks everything
um
okay if I've convinced you that you have
to consciously take in all the minerals
yourself that you can't depend on your
food and certainly you can't depend on
anything that's boxed or packaged or
bottled
there's three types of minerals that you
have to be concerned about one is
metallic minerals metallic minerals are
essentially ground up rocks metallic
minerals are things like oyster shell
eggshell Dolomite Limestone calcium
carbonate Clays of various kinds Mount
marulanite clay sea bed minerals Tums
they're only eight to twelve percent
absorbable When You Reach age 35 to 40
it drops down to three to five percent
and I have to tell you a story here I
ran into a guy at a meeting like this up
at Grand Rapids Michigan and this fellow
owns a porta-potty business you know
that's that green or blue colored
Outhouse man if we'd only had one of
those back when I was a kid we had these
ones with splinters you know in the wood
he said I see something that that
describes that in my Port-A-Potty
business I said what's that he says well
we take those things back to the shop to
clean them out with a pressure hose he
says we put a quarter inch grid
underneath them because kids throw rocks
and sticks and toys in there and if we
don't put a grid there it blocks up the
sewer system it costs us thousands of
dollars to fix it every time we clean
one of those out we find hundreds of
vitamin tablets I said well how do you
know they're vitamin tablets he said
well it's really easy he says right on
the coating it says there Graham M One A
Day Centrum
he says come here he takes me out in the
back of the shop and there's this
literal Mountain
of all these vitamin pills he got out of
his porta potties if you read the labels
on those multiples they say your iron it
comes in the form of iron oxide
what is iron oxide rust
you might as well just go out to an old
railroad track and take your butter
knife and scrape some of that rust off
and lick it and you're going to get your
iron supplement well that's what they're
giving you I'll show you how bad it is
if you take something like calcium
lactate which is a common metallic
mineral let's say it's a calcium tablet
calcium lactate a thousand milligrams if
you take two of those you're not getting
two thousand milligrams of calcium in
fact I have people all the time say well
I took lots of calcium doc I hear you on
the radio talking about calcium and
arthritis and I took 2 000 milligrams of
calcium a day didn't help my arthritis
in fact it got worse and so what kind of
calcium you taking they said calcium
lactate well there's your problem
because only 250 milligrams of that is
metallic calcium so let's say you absorb
10 percent of that then the other 750
milligrams is lactose or milk sugar so
10 of 250 is 25 so if you take two of
those tablets you're not getting 2 000
you're getting 50 milligrams
so to get what you need you need to take
90 of those tablets a day you need to
take 30 with each meal and you got 59
more minerals to go
thank you
then there's those people who want to do
things naturally let's see if you can do
anything good with 10 pounds of spinach
and let's be fair let's see if you can
get a thousand milligrams of magnesium I
pick magnesium because in green leafy
vegetables you have a lot of magnesium
because of the chlorophyll right it's
part of the chlorophyll molecule and any
pound of anything you got 454 grams and
10 pounds of spinach you got 4 540 grams
of which most of that 97 is water and
let's say you have one gram of
chlorophyll in that 10 pounds of spinach
there's 50 milligrams of magnesium you
got to divide that into the Thousand you
want you get a factor of 20 which you
multiply times the 10 you have to eat
200 pounds of spinach you got 58 more
minerals to go
okay so you got to be a pretty big
person to accomplish all this even as
big as I am you can't get it done so I
prefer to supplement rather than do
those things then of course during the
60s the agricultural industry came up
with chelated minerals because Farmers
aren't dumb enough to pay for a dollar
if something that goes into an animal's
mouth and have 99 Cents come out in the
manure I have to really thank Farmers
for being that clever and chelated
minerals are just metallic minerals with
an amino acid or protein or enzyme
wrapped around the metal atom and
increase the absorbability to 40 percent
then the health food industry jumped on
that right away because it was a major
Improvement in absorbability of minerals
the most efficient way to absorb
minerals is liquid they're very small
particle size are seven thousand times
smaller than a red blood cell and
they're negatively charged so you
actually have an electrical or magnetic
gradient that concentrates these
minerals plants have a very interesting
part to play in colloidal minerals
remember we said that plants cannot
create minerals they're not in the soil
plants can't make them
at any rate metallic minerals are taken
up by plants when they're in the soil
plants convert them in their tissues to
colloidal minerals and this is how we
store minerals in our body this is how
we use minerals in our body this is how
we transport minerals from the storage
place to their site of use in the
colloidal Farm well our plants our crops
don't have much in the way of colloidal
minerals in them because we don't have
any metallic minerals in our soil are
these minerals important
You Bet Your Life they're important
[Applause]
information and statements regarding
dietary supplements discussed have not
been evaluated by the Food and Drug
Administration and are not intended to
diagnose treat cure or prevent any
disease